[Musik]
wie es unbekannten amerika präsentiert
das wissen wo es noch ein flug ausfällt
[Musik]
mein name ist arthur honegger acht jahre
lang waren die usa mein zuhause als
korrespondent wenn ich in dieser zeit
ganz schön rumgekommen 47 von 50
bundesstaaten habe ich besucht und auch
heute noch beschäftigt mich dieses große
verrückte land praktisch nonstop bei
meiner fernseharbeit in dieser serie
will ich nun ein unbekanntes amerika
entdecken
abseits der großen politik neue starten
neue menschen neue erfahrungen
[Musik]
auf den postkarten arbeitnehmer ist
anders aus oder
immerhin ist
klingen
aber so ein bisschen regen hält meine
produzentin lisa und kameramann hatte
und mich nicht auf meine erstes
reflektion steht an und surfen das hat
mich schon immer fasziniert
das blaue himmel
[Musik]
wellenreiten das gehört zur vorbei
die schmalztolle zu ermessen
das lebensgefühl auf diesen inseln ist
nirgends so unmittelbar spürbar wie auf
dem surfbrett
das will ich erleben
stefan der uns hier unterstützt lebt
seit zehn jahren auf marie er kennt sich
aus
auch in sachen gastfreundschaft
ich denke
[Applaus]
guten morgen guten morgen bist du das
denn das ding nicht schön dich
kennenzulernen
du wirst heute spaß haben es wird
großartig ich hoffe ja ich bin schon
etwas nervös
es ist so viel wasser ich werde in der
wichtigen guten händen
wasser ist wirklich nicht mein element
aber das den tester vertraue ich sie war
die erste frau die auf maui eine
surfschule gegründet hat die wirft so
schnell nichts um snowboarding und
skateboarding sind ein wichtiger teil
meines lehrers da komm ich her auf dem
snowboard bin ich quasi groß geworden
vielleicht arbeite mit der natur geht
nicht gegen den firmen gute lebensregel
oder hast du mal yoga gemacht wir machen
nicht dass es sein würde in die luft
etwas höher damit du deinen vorderen fuß
zwischen die hände kriegt etwas weiter
nach vorn wenn du kannst der hinteren
fuß wir sind am land das yoga gut fürs
surfen ist das muss ich meiner frau
erzählen sie ist bei uns der yoga crack
immerhin an yoga blattmann trocken
surfing das geht nur nass
die kniebeuge schaue nach vorn
ja
anfängerglück großartig
[Musik]
du bist super das war aber ein
einzigartiges gefühl da draußen besser
gehen und du bist eins mit den elementen
aber es kommt in einem moment zusammen
richtig das hilft ihr die fahrzeuge
freue mich auf die nächste lektion
ich freue mich auf deine fortschritte
bevor du es merkst bist du an der
nordküste mit 20 fuß hohen wellen ich
war es nicht
kleine schritte das denn jedenfalls
glaubt an mich
sie gibt mir ein brett für
fortgeschrittene mit ok ich hoffe mal
ich komme neben dem dreh zum üben bevor
das den ende woche sehen will wie weit
ich gekommen bin
ich bin fast 4000 kilometer vom festland
entfernt mitten im pazifik hawaii ist
der 50 us bundesstaat und für mich der
fünfzigste staat wirklich besucher ein
traum wird wahr
auf der trauminsel passt perfekt auch
weil das fast schon eine pilgerreise für
mich ist auch vorbei liegen nämlich die
wurzeln der subkultur die mein leben bis
heute prägt surfen ist die mutter aller
brett sportarten inklusive skateboarding
und da hat ausgerechnet ein schweizer
sich hier einen namen gemacht
einen sehr schweizerischen namen mike
jucker skateboard hersteller klar muss
ich den kennenlernen
und immer freundlich aus den usa das ist
sehr cool machen also da wurde wir sind
ja nicht der hitze sondern mike jucker
schweizer und das ist wie die letzten
guten 18 jahre ist kein einziger dort
verband im indischen seien auch
gewundert haben warum ich wohnen immer
noch da alles verbrochen
ja das ist wirklich so das ist auch sehr
schön aus ich bin angekommen in bad
iburg
die banken kommen und hier sind alle vor
dir
das ist das blatt vor ist in
zusammenarbeit mit der künstlerin aus
deutschland wo das für uns gemacht hat
dann haben wir das ist für mich
besonders lag trat das kannst du dich
erwarten
ich bin auch ich bin natürlich nur so
war eine damals aber ursprünglich bist
du warum ich meine jetzt das was bringt
der ein züricher da an ich bin ein
skateboard und snowboard fahren und so
für mich ist natürlich zu surfen ist der
ultimative traum kann ich ganz gut
dann können bin dann mal zwei jahre lang
am stück selbst einfach gesagt dass ich
das so lang wie möglich machen
eigene challenge ist angesagt sie sollen
wie möglich müsse zurück in die schweiz
und natürlich die zukünftige frau kann
klemmt eine rechnerische not der in den
usa immer gesagt moment mal probieren
und das ist in not sind und jepsen durch
die straßen gedauert
[Musik]
die boards die micron designt verkauft
er nicht primär auf hawaii aber er
verkauft sie dank aus marketing sicht
ist dieser ort unschlagbar
wo hawaii draufsteht steckt der aloha
lifestyle drin und das ziel ist zum
beispiel spart wo man daher lohnt
gemacht haben um dann über dortmund
spieler fürs iphone urkomischen das ist
so nun laut organisation ich mache ja
eigentlich business award weiteren
starter sich ziehen eigentlichen nutzen
aus dem boot raus nein gott bei und aus
dem off serie gute band aus dem
grundlose fühle ich mich verpflichtet
und es ist auch im hawaiianischen kultur
absolut
longboards sind etwas für leute die gern
einfach so durch die gegend cruisen so
anteil habe ich noch nicht zeit alles
auszuprobieren aber longboards
entschuldigt ja das muss schon mitte
dezember möglich wie bringe ich bin ja
richtig messe kommt vom pushen und okay
ganz verschiedene seychelles schied
wenige der mittelständischen anderem ich
sofort ja schon gut gemeint und da muss
einfach die chance die die pumpe
beweglich machen und du willst es wird
automatisch
deshalb ist der abschluss wird das spiel
beim skaten gehört es dazu sich von den
locals die besten spots zeigen zu lassen
produzentin lisa ist wenig begeistert
ein knochenbruch und unser dreh ist
futsch aber ein paar runs die müssen
jetzt einfach sein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die schwimmfähigkeit
es brauche sie
[Applaus]
[Musik]
etwas geht mir nicht mehr aus dem kopf
zurückgeben an die gemeinschaft hat mike
gesagt das sei hawaiianischen der aloha
spirit das wort begegnet einem hier
überall das heißt hallo auf wiedersehen
und irgendwie auch alles dazwischen
[Musik]
aber was bedeutet aloha wirklich die
suchen die antwort beim traditionellen
volksfest dem verfahren ganz der
einheimische sorgt dafür dass mein
outfit steht
du kannst raylan ob du es tragen ist
oder nicht
hoffentlich stimmt die größe damit nicht
genug wer weiß vielleicht hilft das
blumenmuster ja dabei dem spirit näher
zu kommen ganz sicher hilft es wenn ich
ein paar schritte oder lerne
sein
den schwung gemacht der ist echt
schwierig liga fährt es ist tera monien
meister beim auto hannover
das ist eine kultur show die auf maui
als beste ihrer art gilt die hawaiianer
leben ein leben im gasthof ist das heute
die angestellten hier leben dem alle was
bleibt ich denke bezüglich
gastfreundschaft schlagen wir sogar
unsere südpazifischen co sind möglich
sie erwähnten den aloha spirit davon
höre ich oft was heißt er für sie
was wird damit umschrieben für mich
heißt alu etwas zu tun ohne dafür im
gegenzug etwas zu erwarten
du suchst gutes du tust das richtige
menschen willkommen heißen sie bewirken
sie als teil einer familie betrachten
und genau das machen wir
heutzutage ist alles doch auch viel
business oder überall
es ist die marke für richtig ich möchte
jetzt etwas sagen aber ich kann nicht
das ist politisch doch doch das wird nur
in europa ausgestrahlt
jemand hat versucht das wort allah zu
patentieren das kam nicht gut an bei den
wächtern unserer kultur es muss für alle
der abend rückt näher und damit schaut
am 1
[Applaus]
[Musik]
500 gäste
abend für abend praktisch immer
ausverkauft
ich sag ja hallo anzieht
[Musik]
um die drei millionen touristen besuchen
pro jahr das sind zwanzig mal mehr
menschen als hier leben
[Musik]
das kulinarische highlight wird groß
inszeniert es gibt schwein aus dem herd
ofen der ausgebucht ins fleisch
das gibt einen richtig guten geschmack
dabei es sich gar kein fleisch denn so
dass wir machen das in houston an das
[Musik]
schwein wird heute abend der hauptgang
für hunderte sein
[Applaus]
nicht für mich ich esse tisch
[Musik]
alte hawaiianische bräuche hin oder her
dass wir hier in den usa sind zeigt sich
am perfekten service und am
selbstverständlichen small talk dieses
spiel wird auf hawaii gebraucht oder
speziell weißt du was wirklich ist
in deutschland gibt es ein altes lied
mit dem titel es gibt kein bier auf
hawaii
es gibt leute die glauben es gäbe kein
wie auch das ist verrückt wir haben eine
eigene brauerei
[Musik]
der durst
am nächsten morgen wage ich mich mal
allein aufs band
jeder versuch zeit
die bedingungen sind aber nicht eben
ideal es ist windig richtige wellen aber
gibt es kaum und wasser mag ich immer
noch nicht
auch wenn es 27 grad warm ist
[Musik]
so ganz allein ich alten mann im ozean
ohne ahnung von der brandung
da wird nichts draus
ganz nicht lesen nämlich gleich groß
sind wo sie brechen und so weiter
schon der erfahrung für das team ok das
können was seine raten exakt dort wo die
zurückgekauft
[Musik]
das heißt auf deutsch urlaub das stimmt
zwar nicht trifft die sache aber
ziemlich genau
strand sonne palmen so zeichnen schon
kinder das paradies und genau wie den
garten hin wächst hier jede süße frucht
[Musik]
biobauern lieben die fruchtbare erde
hier
und diese kundschaft sucht die
natürlichkeit die daraus wächst weiter
das wirkt alles hier gibt es etwas was
nicht hier wenn das macht 21 dollar
[Applaus]
das paradies gehört indes nicht
kleinbauern allein
hawaii ist auch ein eldorado für
agrochemie konzerne wie leben die
fruchtbare erde ebenfalls auf maui ist
allen voran monsanto präsent ein global
player im business mit gentech saatgut
und pestiziden und einer der
umstrittensten maltese überhaupt nach
hartnäckigem nachfragen haben wir einen
termin bekommen
der konzern steht stark unter beschuss
kurz vor meinem besuch hat ein
kalifornisches gericht rund 80 millionen
dollar schadenersatz gesprochen
der grund ein monsanto produkt habe beim
kläger krebs verursacht
roth
bewacht ich heiße kein ich bin aber dann
holt mich einerseits sind sie das erste
mal vor ein ja und das ist der
fünfzigste bundesstaat den ich besuche
seit sommer 20 18 gehört die firma dem
bayer konzern aus leverkusen der hier
puncto gentech ein freundlicheres umfeld
am trifft als in europa ihr könntet
rüben karten dann treffen wir uns bei
den bänken und reden ein bisschen bevor
wir ins feld gehen
ich bin ja mal gespannt wie man bei
monsanto den geist von aloha definiert
gegeben vor der tour für alle gäste
sicherheits instruktionen
unser größtes anliegen auf der farm ist
sicherheit falls irgendetwas passiert
ihr einen kratzer habt oder sonst
irgendetwas dann sagt bleibt in unserer
nähe
und wenn sie auf dem feld sind bitte
seid vorsichtig wenn ihr aus dem bus
steigt
ich werde an eurer seite sein weil es
ist sehr steinig da draußen ist jemand
hier auf bienen allergisch ich glaube
ich frage weil ich keine medikamente
dabei haben wir werden in ein feld mit
vielen blumen gehen
da gibt es manchmal probleme mit bienen
und wespenstichen
wir nehmen den bus im 21 wir zeigen euch
nicht die ganze farbe sondern wir
konzentrieren uns darauf dass er
praktisch auf all unseren farmen sehen
würde eine gute auswahl aus
monsanto testet auf maui gentech mais
die samen werden dann patentiert dann
führt mich zuerst auf ein feld pflanzen
gerade wild wuchern zur boden erholung
das klima auf hawaii erlaubt jedoch drei
bis vier ernten im jahr
das spart zeit und zeit ist geld klar
die entwickelten samen sollen
resistenzen gegen schädlinge und
steigende temperaturen
es gibt länder wie die usa die offene
sehen uns bezüglich gentechnisch
veränderten pflanzen im gegensatz zu
europa dass dieser technik eher
skeptisch gegenübersteht
denken sie das wird sich ändern ich
glaube es geht um bildung die
wissenschaft verändert sich schneller
als die leute mit handeln können leuten
die in der biologie stunde eingeschlafen
sind ist es schwierig zu erklären wie
biotechnologie
es ist auch kompliziert
menschen entscheiden aufgrund ihres
bauchgefühls und es ist ihr recht zu
wählen was sie essen
ich finde es braucht alle wir müssen
alle mit einbeziehen und wenn es fragen
gibt lasst uns richtig darüber will 200
leute arbeiten auf maui für monsanto auf
ganzer weise in das 600
nicht was es versprochen wir stellen
euch jetzt dem team vor ich mag wir ja
alle diese hemden tragen
richtig hawaiianisch hallo herr kommt
von ihnen stimmt aber viele denken dass
man bei monsanto schutzanzüge trägt
macht ihr das nicht aber ihr müsst euch
hin und wieder schützen wenn ihr es gibt
immer regeln und vorschriften die sie
regeln befolgen wie regel heute ist hart
und gut darin aussehen wie besorgen
diese samen haben die gewünschten
merkmale zb die resistenz gegen eine
bestimmte krankheit gehabt sie also
schon so weit entwickelt wie ihr sie
dort ja wir pflanzen sie dann in diese
sagt nach zehn tagen haben wir dass die
wachsen tatsächlich schnell und am
schluss sind sie dann so groß ungefähr
drei monate drei monate zeigt mir wie
das funktioniert mit der kontrollierten
befruchtung ich bin drum im
biounterricht auch manchmal
eingeschlafen
am morgen nimmst du diesen samt
beschreibung heißt das passiert hier
viereinhalb millionen mal pro jahr
das überlebende menschen hängt davon ab
dass jemand gewillt ist diese dinge zu
tun das ist das also was ihnen ihre
arbeit bedeutet das herz
ja das ist etwas sehr persönliches
nein die treibhäuser sind für uns tabu
stattdessen zeigt uns team die maschine
mit der die erde für die setzlinge
präpariert wird
eine dicke erdrutsch wie entwickelt
diesen samen über mehrere generationen
weiter sammeln dabei daten und werden
sie dann stellen sie sich das hier nicht
als ein experimentierlabor vor sondern
eher als einen ort der samenproduktion
und das ziel wäre dann pestizide
verwenden zu können ohne an die pflanzen
zu schädigen
das ist eines unserer produkte die
konsumenten wollen bessere produkte die
besser für die umwelt sind und weniger
zeit brauchen und bauern brauchen
rendite es ist schwierig das alles unter
einen hut zu bringen weniger zeug also
weniger pestizide und weniger von einem
aber das ist ja gerade die hauptkritik
dass hier mehr geschätzt werde dagegen
der häufigen herrn unser ziel ist
weniger von an weniger von allem außer
profi ihr seid ja großem herbizid
geschäft eine pflanze zu haben die gegen
ein bestimmtes herbizide resistent ist
macht sinn damit handlungs antwort
beides verkaufen
es ist kein geheimnis unser job ist geld
alle haben ihre eigenen bedürfnisse
es ist herausfordert das ist alles was
wir für euch das ist die tour
es war uns ein vergnügen
naja so richtig entspannt verlief dieser
besuch nicht als gentechnik und muss
sich monsanto ja einiges anhören rund um
die welt in havanna ist der widerstand
aber auch sehr lokal
ich kann hier nicht beliebt zu sein
gm also genveränderte pflanzen das passt
in den augen vieler einheimischer so gar
nicht zu hallo ich treffe gleich einen
wortführer des protests der das
agrochemie business software erschüttert
hat alica atheist politiker ehemaliger
biobauer und jemand der bereit ist zu
kämpfen für das erbe seiner
hawaiianischen ramel
wenn sie kennenzulernen videos von ihnen
gesehen
sie sind sehr bekannt ich habe mich
immer an das konzept von aloha
eingehalten
hallo einer bedeutet liebe zum land
früher waren wir für das überleben
abhängig vom sammeln deshalb wussten wir
über die jahreszeiten und den zyklus der
einzelnen pflanzen genau bescheid
wir wussten jetzt ist blütezeit jetzt
ist und man ging hin und pflückte
einfach die früchte die es gab auch in
bezug auf das meer und die buchten wir
wussten woher der wind und die wellen
kann ich gehöre zu jener generation
vor vier jahren spaltete eine abstimmung
die insel eine knappe mehrheit sagte
damals ja zu einem moratorium für
genveränderte pflanzen
ein gericht hob die entscheidung danach
zwar auf doch der unmut ist geblieben
alica will mir einen befreundeten
biobauern vorstellen
der weg zu ihm führt vorbei an den
ruinen einer zuckerfabrik
die zeiten als zucker gold wert war auf
maui sind geschichte also zur info hier
beginnt die fahrenheit
und was machst du hier an früher war
hier auf dem ganzen land zuckerrohr im
grunde eine monokultur
es war eine monokultur während 144
jahren gab es nur ananas und zuckerrohr
auf diesem weg und du versuchst es
braucht ja unsere vision ist dass wieder
leben in den boden zu bringen
wenn man in die erde kein leben hat hat
man einfach nur die barbie genannt
angela be sad statt monokulturen lieber
pflanzen mit kultur carlo zb die
hawaiianische urknall das ist karl und
heute gibt es wieder mehr menschen italo
essen immer mehr
aber leider ist carlo und der so
genannte bei den man daraus macht für
die leute auf hawaii zu einem luxusgut
geworden dass man ein
grundnahrungsmittel war ist also nun ein
luxusgut richtig das ist für dich
wisst ihr in der schweiz diese tradition
wenn der reporter etwas bekommt dann
gibt er es direkt an seine produzentin
weiter damit kann
agrarland ist knapp auf maui stadt
gentech produkte sollten hier
einheimische sorten angebaut werden
finden onkel be die insel soll sich
selbst versorgen können
heute muss das grüne paradies 90 prozent
der lebensmittel importieren
das sind schweine die ich für den liner
notes ist
wir werden ihn jetzt nicht erzählen wie
sie enden tolle party ihr werdet sie
aber nicht
wir machen hier eine bestimmte form von
beide pflegen wir bringen viele schweine
auf eine kleine fläche und lassen sie
düngen dadurch brauche ich keinen
künstlichen dünger wir wollen versuchen
überhaupt nichts mehr zuzuführen
die ursprüngliche erde zurück wie im
wald der wald ist unser lehrer wenn du
in den wald christ siehst du keine
monokultur
es geht um werte oder geld will man den
kurzfristigen gewinn setzt man aufs geld
das land ist dabei unwichtig weil es
geht nur darum die ernte zu steigen
das müssen viele bauern zu machen oder
fast die ganze welt tut dass wir wollen
davon wegkommen
wenn er wie kann mich fragt kann ich ihn
direkt in die augen schauen und sagen ja
ich mache alloheim und ich mache mal am
wir mussten durch diese erfahrung mit
chemikalien und perspektiven durch die
weder gut sind für den boden noch gut
für die tiere noch gut für die menschen
ein geschlossener kreislauf aber kann
nur mit hallo liebe und mit einer dann
haben wir die liebe zum land der respekt
dass gewisse macht hallo anna ist die
liebe zum land
malama einer heißt sich um das land
kümmern
maradona dann sich um mutter erde
[Musik]
hallo habe
das ist mehr als alles andere eine
lebenseinstellung und das spüren wir
hier besonders das dorf peuchar an der
nordküste zieht mit seinem serve
aussteiger aus aller welt an
ich frage einfach mal drauflos was aloha
für sie bedeutet
[Musik]
wie geht's wir drehen einen
dokumentarfilm wir kommen aus der
schweiz
um was geht es
das aloha heißt übersetzt heißt es den
atem teilen wie wenn du also mit jemand
anderem gemeinsam ist oder wie durch
eine andere person als individuen
existierten
also im selben rhythmus mit den anderen
leben
das ist die wörtliche übersetzung es
geht um liebe aber worüber ich wirklich
sprechen möchte ist der kalender der mai
darüber lehre rückt art von kalender des
papstes und kehrt zur natürlichen zeit
zurück diese umfasst 13 monate und 28
tage
das ist die natürliche zeit wie gott sie
kreiert hat das ist meine kurze
botschaft ich würde gern vom kalender
wird kommen album mehr frei zusammen es
ist etwas das in gefahr ist in gefahr
warum weil es viele leute gibt die den
geist der insel nicht verstehen sie
kommen und folgen ihren eigenen
interessen immobilien leute und santo
[Musik]
aloha spirit kann verschiedene
bedeutungen haben vor allem das heißt
das richtige tun
[Musik]
man soll nicht angst haben ein lächeln
zu verschenken oder jemanden zu umarmen
oder auf der straße zu helfen
bono eben die leute lächeln tatsächlich
das ist nicht überall so das ist
jean-pierre ist eine der größten städte
der welt
alle lächeln wenn sie hierher kommen gut
also viel bontempi tanks gewinn
rico
gleich bei bayer um die ecke liegt rocky
beach der surf spot auf maui eigentlich
hoheitsgebiet derjenigen die es wirklich
drauf haben
kommt ihr jeden tag da draußen sind ein
paar echte profis unglaublich gerade
beobachtet was macht ihr hier
wir drehen einen dokumentarfilm nun ein
worüber über marie bringst du die maßen
rein ich sagen wie teuer sie zeigt es
nicht zu einladen
es ist schrecklich
da soll es auch nicht sein
das stimmt ich habe fotos gesehen ja es
ist ein binnenland wir können nicht aber
ihr habt stimmt das ist der ausgleich
schnee das ist mein element die brandung
von hoher keeper ist das nicht mit
dustin packe ich mich trotzdem rein
ich meine es meine rote rakete
es ist schnell und wendig eine gute
mischung zwischen langem und kurzem red
wir suchen einen teil des strandes wo
wir den profis nicht im weg sind
ich hoffe mal die wellen sind dort dann
auch nicht ganz so hoch hoffentlich
schaffst du es das brett zu lenken
dein ziel heute ist die kontrolle zu
behalten und auf den wellen zu kurven
du bist jetzt an der nordküste ich würde
gerne länger bleiben hier und und besser
werden
das wollen alle nach arbeit sehen und
surfen lernen
bereit hätte ich nicht gedacht dass ich
hierher komme aber mit dir fühle ich
mich sicher
so sicher man sich halt fühlen kann den
bilden wasser ausgesetzt
da fliegen sogar profis immer
für mich gibt es jetzt aber nur die
flucht nach vorn
die wellen sind zu hoffen durch zum
paddeln
ich habe darum die turtle robert auf dem
rücken luftanhalten unten durch aber
eigentlich will ich ja oben drauf stehen
sowie das denn
[Musik]
wozu ich erst mal aufstehen müsste
[Applaus]
fast zwei stunden schlucke ich wasser
und partner mir die arme ab aber ein
paar sekunden aloha sind es wert
[Musik]
super gemacht das war harte arbeit es
war ein paar hast du gut david danke
erste mich am leben gehalten hast sogar
schweizer männer können surfen wie ein
neuer server
warum hast du dein geschäft eigentlich
auf frauen ausgerichtet eine nische für
frauen ist wichtig surfen können stark
männlich dominierte spät sein
es kann sehr einschüchternd sein wenn du
so eine reihe sie ist mit männern die
sich so vor einstürzen
frauen bringen einen anmutigen aspekt
heim
männer können viel mit ihren muskeln
machen aber surfen ist voller anmut als
einer der ersten frauen hat das denn
auch die berüchtigste werde von hawaii
bezwungen
[Musik]
als ich auf dieser welle schulde ich
völlige ruhe obwohl es das
schrecklichste den war das ich je
gesehen habe
aber ich liebe es das adrenalin zu
spüren und völlig präsent zu sein
völlig präsent das vereint und server
skater snowboardern
der moment ist alles was zählt
[Musik]
viel zeit bleibt uns nicht mehr auf neu
zum mythischen städtchen hahne aber
müssen wir unbedingt das hören wir von
allen seiten erreichbar ist es nur über
eine dschungel straße in hama wohl der
wahre geist von hawaii überlebt haben
und tatsächlich ohne es geplant zu haben
finde ich mich an einer veranstaltung
wieder an der wir die einzigen nicht
herr aller sind es ist der tag der
makkabispiele
[Musik]
hey ich bin also wir haben gehört dass
man hierher kommen muss maki das ist man
muss zwischen die stäbe treffen teil
weiß wovon er spricht er war der erste
hätte diese wettkämpfe gewonnen hat die
makkabispiele sind so etwas wie die
olympischen spiele von haben es ist eine
große ehre dem champions titel zu
erhalten
denn anoki dann kannst du mit
herausgestreckter brust herum gehen
stellt uns den antwort der alles
organisiert hat und ich merke die spiele
sind auch ein politisches statement
willkommen in unserem land wir feiern
heute den unabhängigkeitstag der
hawaiianische nation
unser land wurde 1893 ins exil getrieben
von unseren freunden den amerikanern und
ihren geschäftsinteressen arbeitest du
morgen morgen ist mein 27 geburtstag
wenn ich sage willkommen in meinem land
meine ich das königreich hat obwohl
viele denken dass hier amerika ist kann
das niemand belegen da mal ins
justizministerium
die können wir nicht sagen wie sie
erworben haben
also wenn sie mich fragen sind sie heute
der könig von arbeit ein einziger könig
ist jesus christ ich bin nur gewählte
vertreter mannes bzw
gibt es da ein geheimnis eine bestimmte
technik
falls du es herausfinden ist sagt dass
das wirkt dann ist das auch teil deiner
kultur ist es wichtig an solchen
anlässen seine herbe zu feiern
unbedingt es ist wie bei allen anderen
die auch ihre kultur feiern
also es ist etwas eigenes und nicht
unbedingt gegen die usa gerichtet wir
sind nicht gegen irgendwas
wir sind einfach für hawaii wie kann man
nicht ich weiß wir haben strahlt gutes
essen
das wird nie ausgehen bevor hawaii 1959
den usa als 50 der staat beitrag wurden
die inseln als us territorium betrachtet
lokale sprache und kultur unterdrückt
nichts als das gras berührt
danke du hast mir glück gebracht
[Musik]
im alten hawaii gab es eine zeit für
krieg und eine zeit für frieden erzählt
mal mehr in friedenszeiten erfolgte das
kräftemessen am spielen wie dies die
marke die wettkämpfe hier in hanau
finden erst zum vierten mal statt
bist du immer noch im spiel
ja bis jetzt aus ich bin immer noch
dabei
es gibt nur einen ersten champion ich
werde immer der erste bleibt
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
der tag in hanau hat mir gezeigt wie
wichtig den hawaiianer ihre
eigenständigkeit ist gelebt in spiel und
spaß
friedenstal ganz eindeutig
[Musik]
ja
apa
[Musik]
zum schluss zieht es mich noch einmal zu
den servern von hawkeye puppy
[Musik]
ich finds halt einfach wahnsinnig
faszinierend man kann 1000 eine million
mal anschauen das hat so eine
leichtigkeit sondern grazie mit den
elementen davon kriegt man glaube ich
nie genug haben
hat das was mit ihr los berichtete
wahrscheinlich schon her
also geht auch darum dass man ein
bisschen loslässt dass man nichts
erzwingen und beim surfen geht es auch
darum
zu warten auf die welle die dann richtig
ist und sich dann ein stück weit der
auch hinzugeben
ohne ihn
die nicht
[Musik]
wie
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wieso unbekannten amerika präsentiert
wurde von swiss für haben türen wo es
noch ein flug ausfällt
[Musik]